Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
AMANDA REVEALED
A SHOCKING SECRET.
Amanda: I'M LEGALLY BLIND.
(gasps)
Amanda: AND I'M GONNA BE
ABOUT 30 WHEN I GO
COMPLETELY BLIND.
Tyra: DRAMATIC MAKEOVERS
LED TO FIERCE NEW LOOKS
AND BOLDER PERSONALITIES.
WHEN JULIE TOLD THE JUDGES
SHE'D RATHER BE A FASHION
MERCHANDISER THAN A MODEL,
SHE WAS SENT HOME.
11 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
(alarm clock beeping)
Kelle: I'D BEEN SO CONFIDENT
THROUGH THIS WHOLE THING,
BUT MY LAST PANEL--
GOD, THAT WAS HARD.
MY BIGGEST CHALLENGE
IS REALIZING THAT,
HEY, YOU DON'T KNOW IT ALL.
Kristi: I AM THE LEAST
CONFIDENT,
AND I FEEL A LITTLE...
INTIMIDATED OF THE OTHER GIRLS.
I HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO,
AND THEY KNOW THAT.
Jennipher: BEING IN NEW YORK
IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT
THAN BEING IN IDAHO.
THERE'S LOTS OF DRAMA THAT
GOES ON IN THIS COMPETITION.
cBUT I STILL LIKE EVERYBODY
IN THE HOUSE.
AND YOU HAVE TO GET ALONG
TO LIVE TOGETHER.
Norelle: COME ON, COME ON.
COME ON, COME ON, COME ON.
Kristi: YOU GUYS,
WE GOT TYRA MAIL.
I'M GONNA READ IT.
"SCHOOL IS IN SESSION THIS A.M.
GRAB YOUR SWEATS AND SNEAKERS
AND HEAD FOR THE GYM."
SO WE HAVE FIVE MINUTES.
Eva: OH, WOW.
Jennipher: SO WE SHOW UP.
WE COME IN
AND IT'S LIKE A THEATER ROOM
AND THERE'S A STAGE
AND A RUNWAY SET UP.
AND WE'RE LIKE,
"OH, THIS IS AWESOME.
WE'RE GONNA DO RUNWAY TODAY."
Women: (gasping)
(applauding)
Toccara: MISS J. COMES DOWN.
SHE HAS HER LITTLE APPLE,
AND SHE'S JUST FABULOUS.
Jennipher: J. ALEXANDER
IS PROBABLY THE FUNNIEST MAN
I'VE EVER SEEN.
Kristi: OKAY, WHY DOESN'T
SOMEONE EXPLAIN J. TO US?
HE WEARS HEELS, AND NO ONE SAYS
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
J.: SO, LADIES,
WELCOME TO RUNWAY 101.
CALL ME MISS J.
REMEMBER,
AT THE J. RUNWAY SCHOOL--
PRACTICE MAKES PERFECT.
AND A PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF THAT IS...
MISS AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
HERSELF--
Eva: AAH!
(cheers and applause)
Amanda: MISS YOANNA
WALKS ON DOWN, AND IT'S PRETTY
ENTHRALLING TO SEE SOMEBODY
THAT HAS THE EXPERIENCE.
Yoanna: HI, HOW ARE YOU?
Women: HI!
Woman: SO HOW'S IT GOING?
Yoanna: IT'S GOING
REALLY WELL.
MY LIFE HAS JUST TOTALLY BEEN
FLIPPED AROUND INSIDE AND OUT,
AND JUST BE PREPARED.
Kristi: SO
WHILE YOU WERE HERE,
DO YOU REMEMBER FEELING
DISCOURAGED?
JUST BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO LIKE,
CONTINUE TO BE CONFIDENT?
Yoanna: I THINK AS FAR AS
CONFIDENCE,
MY PHILOSOPHY IS DON'T LOOK
AT THE OTHER PERSON,
WHAT THEY'RE DOING,
IT'S WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
IT'S WHAT YOU CAN DO
FOR YOURSELF.
'CAUSE I THINK IF YOU REALLY
START WORRYING ABOUT
THE OTHER GIRLS,
THAT YOU LOSE FOCUS.
YOU LOSE YOUR CONCENTRATION
AND THAT'S THE KEY.
SO I KNOW WHAT YOU GUYS
ARE GOING THROUGH,
BUT IT'S WORTH IT.
IT'S SUCH A SHORT TIME,
AND YOU'RE SO YOUNG,
AND YOU'LL SLEEP WHEN
YOU'RE DEAD SO...
Nicole: YOANNA--SHE'S SAYING,
YOU KNOW,
STAY FOCUSED ON YOURSELF.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT
WHAT THE OTHER GIRLS ARE DOING.
AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY SOUND ADVICE.
Amanda: ALL RIGHT, YAY!
Yoanna: MEETING THE GIRLS,
IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
BEING ON THE OTHER SIDE.
J. IS GONNA RESHAPE AND MOLD
THESE GIRLS TODAY,
AND HE'S GONNA GIVE THEM
THE TOOLS TO SUCCEED.
J.: OKAY, GIRLS,
I NEED TO SEE LEGS.
Women: WHOO!
J.: FIND YOUR SIZE.
AND IF IT'S NOT YOUR SIZE,
MAKE IT WORK. MAKE IT HAPPEN.
Amanda: OKAY, SERIOUSLY,
WHERE'S THE 8 IN THIS?
Norelle: I AM NOT USED TO
WEARING, LIKE, HIGH HEELS.
WHICH--I'M WORKING
ON WEARING HIGH HEELS
BUT NOT TO THIS EXTREME.
J.: YOU ARE NOW
IN THE "J. WALKING SCHOOL"--
WHERE POSTURE IS EVERYTHING.
OKAY, BABY, HIT IT.
BOOKS ARE GONNA HELP THE GIRLS
WITH THEIR BALANCE FOR POSTURE.
Yaya: (gasps)
J.: BALANCE IS EVERYTHING!
POSTURE, BALANCE,
POSTURE, BALANCE.
MISS T., HONEY, YOU--YOU--
J.: (imitates buzzer)
MAKE IT WORK.
NOW FORGET THE BOOK ON THE HEAD.
Jennipher: AH!
J.: Y'ALL ARE SO BEAT UP.
J.: OKAY, OKAY,
YOU GAVE A LITTLE BIT EXTRA.
Ann: AND THAT, LADIES,
IS HOW IT'S DONE.
J.: YOU WALK LIKE
YOU'RE CHEWING GUM
BETWEEN YOUR LEGS.
I LOVE IT.
Eva: THE GIRLS DON'T KNOW
THAT I STRUGGLE WITH THE FACT
THAT I'M THE SHORTEST GIRL
IN THE HOUSE.
I FEEL LIKE THE TALLEST GIRL,
AND I ACT LIKE THE TALLEST GIRL.
J.: IT'S REALLY FUNNY,
BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT TO FALL,
BUT YOU'RE NOT
LETTING IT HAPPEN.
Eva: IT'S NOT GONNA FALL.
J.: OH! OH!
KELLE--SHE NEEDS TO BE LOOSE,
TO BE LESS...
NICOLE--SHE IS AFRAID
TO REALLY LET GO.
CASSIE--I THINK SHE CAN DO
A LOT BETTER,
BUT SHE'S HOLDING BACK.
IT'S HELPFUL.
IT GIVES YOU SOME HEIGHT.
AND AMANDA--SHE STANDS OUT.
IT'S HER EYES.
THAT'S ALL SHE NEEDS--
THOSE EYES.
Amanda: I HAVE
A DEGENERATIVE DISEASE--
RETINITIS PIGMENTOSA.
AND EVENTUALLY
I WILL BE COMPLETELY BLIND.
MODELING WILL PROMOTE
CERTAIN CHALLENGES.
I'M NOT GONNA LET IT AFFECT ME
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT IT TO.
J.: WHAT I THINK WE'RE
LACKING IS GRACE AND ELEGANCE.
J.: JENNIPHER, I DON'T FEEL
AN OUNCE OF GRACE
IN ANY OF THOSE BONES.
THERE'S NO LIGHTNESS TO HER.
IT'S ALMOST...
MISS TOCCARA,
WE KNOW YOU'RE PLUS-SIZED.
SUCK THE GUT, BABY.
ANYTHING HANGING OUT,
IT LOOKS NASTY.
J.: KRISTI--
I THINK THAT HER LOOK
IS QUITE DEAD.
SHE NEEDS TO COME ALIVE.
SHE NEEDS TO SMILE
WITH HER FACE.
YOU ARE SERVING A PLATE OF STEAM
IN A BOWL OF NOTHING.
Kristi: I KNOW
I WASN'T VERY GOOD.
IT'S JUST BECAUSE
I WAS THINKING SO MUCH.
J.: THERE'S A LOT OF...
YAYA--
SHE'S TOO MUCH OF A DANCER.
TRY NOT TO DO THIS.
NORELLE IS CONCENTRATING
TOO MUCH ON THE CLOTHING
THAN HER BODY ITSELF.
Norelle: I WAS SERIOUSLY
THE WORST GIRL WALKING,
AND, LIKE, FALLING.
THIS IS SOMETHING I WOULD DO.
BUT I'M NOT GONNA
LOOK LIKE A DUMB, LIKE, IDIOT.
J.: SO GO AHEAD.
Jennipher: J. MADE US WEAR
THESE HUGE HEADDRESSES,
AND THEY WERE THE MOST AWFULEST
THINGS TO WEAR IN THE WORLD.
J.: THE LAST FALL
WINTER COUTURE SHOW
FOR CHRISTIAN DIOR,
THERE WAS A LOT OF HEADDRESSES
INVOLVED IN THE SHOW.
YOU REALLY HAD A LOT
OF WORK TO DO.
THERE IS NO REHEARSAL.
Norelle: WHOA.
Eva: (laughs)
J.: OKAY.
(claps twice)
RIGHT HERE, LISTEN.
EVERYTHING THAT I TAUGHT YOU,
YOU WILL BE TESTED ON IT
BECAUSE REMEMBER,
THIS IS A COMPETITION.
AND FOR BEING SUCH GOOD SPORTS,
I'M TAKING YOU OUT
TO A PRIVATE PARTY TONIGHT.
Women: YAY!
J.: IT'S JUST SIMPLE
MODELS OUT ON THE TOWN
HAVING A FIERCE TIME, OKAY?
Women: ALL RIGHT! YAY!
Jennipher: WE GET TO A CLUB--
LIKE A DANCE CLUB,
AND PEOPLE WERE WAITING
OUT FRONT.
AND WE'RE LIKE,
"HUH, THIS IS WEIRD."
J.: RIGHT UP THIS WAY, GIRLS.
Norelle: WE WALK INTO
THIS ROOM AND THEN, YOU KNOW,
I JUST TURNED MY HEAD.
Women: (screaming)
Norelle: MY FAVORITE
DESIGNERS IN THE WHOLE WORLD--
HEATHERETTE IS STANDING
RIGHT IN FRONT OF ME.
J.: I WANT YOU GUYS
TO MEET MY FRIENDS.
Norelle: THEY'RE MY FRIENDS!
J.: RICHIE RICH,
TRAVER RAINS,
FROM THE HOUSE OF HEATHERETTE.
WORK IT OUT!
SO, GUYS, TELL THE GIRLS,
AND TELL US, I MEAN,
SOME OF THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU'VE DRESSED.
SOME OF THE MOST FABULOUS
AND INCREDIBLE PEOPLE
THAT YOU'VE WORKED WITH.
Richie: SARAH JESSICA PARKER,
PARIS HILTON.
Norelle: I LOVE THE WAY
PARIS HILTON DRESSES,
AND I LOVE PARIS HILTON.
Richie: GWEN STEFANI,
AEROSMITH, NICOLE KIDMAN.
Eva: OH.
Richie: COURTNEY LOVE.
J.: HOLD SOME OF THESE NAMES
THEY'VE BEEN DROPPING.
Richie: LOTS OF GORGEOUS
MODELS.
J.: THEIR SHOW IS USUALLY
THE HOTTEST TICKET IN TOWN
DURING NEW YORK FASHION WEEK.
IT'S SO HOT THAT I DON'T
GET A TICKET.
(imitates sizzling noise)
THAT'S OKAY.
BUT GUESS WHAT, GIRLS.
YOU ARE STARRING IN IT LIVE!
Women: (screaming)
OH, MY GOD!
J.: OKAY, HAIR AND MAKEUP--
YOUR TEAM AWAITS YOU THERE.
GO FOR IT!
Richie: THE THEME OF THIS
SHOW IS "THE CIRCUS OF PANIC"
SO...
Traver: (chuckles)
Richie: WITHOUT A LITTLE BIT
OF PANICKING, AND LIKE,
ENTHUSIASM, IT WOULDN'T
CONVEY ANYTHING ON THE RUNWAY.
Toccara: (laughs)
Amanda: I AM SO STOKED.
AS LONG AS I SEE THE RUNWAY
BEFORE, I'LL BE COOL.
Norelle: WHAT?!
HOLY CRAP.
Nicole: OKAY.
Danilo: OKAY, GO TO MAKEUP
TO FINISH YOU OFF.
Cassie: OKAY.
Richie: I'M EXCITED.
Traver: THEY'RE GONNA
ROCK IT.
Richie: DO WE HAVE TO WALK
ON THAT RUNWAY?
IT'S LIKE THIS...
Amanda: COULD I TAKE A PEEK
AT THE RUNWAY?
Amanda: I DON'T THINK
I'M GONNA GET A CHANCE
TO SEE IT BEFOREHAND.
SO, UH, THAT KINDA SUCKS.
I'M LEGALLY BLIND DURING
THE DAYTIME,
AND AT NIGHT IT'S...
COMPLETELY BLIND.
Norelle: I SAW THE SHOES
WERE, LIKE, SO BIG.
WE DIDN'T GET TO SEE
THE RUNWAY AT ALL.
AND THESE SHOES WERE RIDICULOUS.
I WAS LIKE, "OH, MY GOD."
Amanda: I MEAN, I UNDERSTAND
THEY DIDN'T WANT ME TO HAVE
AN UNFAIR ADVANTAGE.
BUT I'M JUST TRYING TO GET UP
TO THE SAME PLAYING FIELD
AS EVERYBODY ELSE.
Man: EVA!
Eva: OKAY, EVA'S COMING!
Man: I NEED CASSIE.
Man #2: GOTTA GO LINE UP.
Cassie: I'LL GO.
Man: I NEED AMANDA.
Amanda: I'M GETTING
SCARED NOW.
I DON'T WANNA FALL OFF
THE RUNWAY.
J.: REMEMBER,
THIS IS A CHALLENGE,
AND EVERYTHING YOU DO
FROM THIS POINT ON,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE JUDGED ON.
Woman: OKAY,
YOU GUYS, LINE UP.
Cassie: AND EVERYONE
WAS, LIKE, SO EXCITED
BECAUSE WE WERE DOING
A FASHION SHOW FOR HEATHERETTE,
AND IT WAS A CHALLENGE.
J.: GIRLS, AT THE END
OF THE RUNWAY
YOU HAVE TO STEP UP
ON THE ROUND, CIRCULAR STAGE,
POSE AND WALK AROUND IT.
Amanda: HAVING REALLY BAD
DAYTIME VISION
AND THEN, AT NIGHT,
I'M BASICALLY COMPLETELY BLIND,
IT WAS REALLY, REALLY SCARY.
Man: JENNIPHER, NOW!
Jennipher: I WAS SO NERVOUS.
"ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY GET READY,
YOU KNOW, WE GOTTA GO.
YOU'RE FIRST UP."
Audience: (cheers)
Man: LET'S GO, EVA.
(cheers and applause)
Eva: I WAS SO HIGH
BEING ONSTAGE.
THOUGH I'M SHORT,
I LOVE RUNWAY.
IT'S SO FLY TO ME.
Man: I NEED CASSIE.
GO.
Man: I NEED ANN. GO, GO, GO.
J.: LET'S GO, KELLE.
Man: I NEED NICOLE.
TOCCARA.
(cheers and applause)
Toccara: I LOVE THE CROWD.
I LOVE TO HEAR EVERYONE CHEER.
I LOVE TO BE THE SPOTLIGHT.
I LIKE TO BE THE CENTER
OF ATTENTION.
I LOVE TO BE A SHOWSTOPPER
SO I LOVED IT.
Eva: TOCCARA ACTUALLY
DISCLOSED THIS TO ME,
THAT SHE THOUGHT SHE WAS GONNA
WIN BECAUSE SHE GOT A LOT
OF APPLAUSE.
YOU GOT APPLAUSE
BECAUSE YOUR... WERE OUT, GIRL.
Man: WHERE'S YAYA?
GO.
Richie: GOOD!
Man: I NEED KRISTI.
Kristi: WHOO!
THERE WERE LOTS OF GUYS
STANDING DOWN THERE,
AND I WAS LIKE, "YOU CAN TOTALLY
SEE UP MY SKIRT.
I KNOW YOU CAN."
AND YOU GET HIGHER
WHEN YOU GET UP ON THE CIRCLE.
I WAS JUST LIKE,
"GET ME OFF THIS CIRCLE.
GET ME DOWN AWAY FROM HERE."
Richie: NOBODY'S FALLEN DOWN
YET, RIGHT?
Man: I NEED AMANDA.
Amanda: I COULDN'T SEE
THE RUNWAY.
PEOPLE WOULDN'T EVEN TELL ME
THE NUMBER OF STEPS LEADING UP
TO THE RUNWAY.
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED.
AS SOON AS I HIT THAT FIRST STEP
I SAW THAT THE RUNWAY
HAD GLITTER ALL OVER IT.
I WAS LIKE, "THANK YOU!"
'CAUSE THE GLITTER SAVED ME.
Norelle: IT FEELS SO GOOD
THAT I GOT TO BE IN THE SHOW.
I MEAN,
IT'S LIKE A DREAM COME TRUE.
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE
I'M NEVER GONNA GET OVER IT.
Man: GO, NORELLE.
(record needle scratches)
Man: SHE JUST FELL DOWN.
Richie: OH, MY GOD!
Norelle: MY BIGGEST DREAM--
HEATHERETTE FASHION SHOW.
MY WORST NIGHTMARE--FALLING.
ALL IN THE SAME NIGHT.
Richie: THAT'S GONNA
MAKE YOU A STAR, BABY.
J.: THE GIRLS ARE PSYCHED.
THEY TOOK THEIR FIRST SHOT
OF FASHION CRACK.
Amanda: WALKING IN
WAS FIERCE.
AND THEN LIKE, "BOOM,"
45 MINUTES LATER
THEY'RE LOOKING AT US.
J.: WHERE'S YOUR STICK?
SEE THIS IS WHAT I SHOULD'VE
HAD TODAY GIVING YOU
THE WALKING LESSON.
WHEN YOU'RE IN, LIKE,
A DIMLY LIT ROOM,
WHAT DO YOU SEE?
Amanda: MY PERIPHERAL
IS SO BAD AT NIGHT.
LIKE, I'M COMPLETELY
NIGHT-BLIND.
AFTER THE RUNWAY WAS DONE,
I MADE A MISTAKE BY SAYING
TO J., "YOU KNOW ABOUT MY EYES,
RIGHT?"
Toccara: THE RUMOR IS
AMANDA'S GETTING SPECIAL
TREATMENT 'CAUSE SHE'S--
'CAUSE SHE'S... HERE.
J.: IF MISS AMANDA DID GET
ANY KIND OF SPECIAL TREATMENT,
I DIDN'T SEE IT.
BECAUSE I WAS JUST TOLD
OF YOUR CONDITION.
Amanda: I WASN'T ALLOWED
TO SEE THE RUNWAY BEFOREHAND.
J.: I SAID NO.
NOBODY CAN SEE IT.
SO YOU BLAME HER.
Eva: BUT IF YOU'RE GONNA
BE A MODEL,
AND YOU'RE GONNA DO THIS,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
Amanda: YEAH, AND I,
YOU KNOW, I DID MY THING
OUT THERE WITHOUT SEEING IT,
YOU KNOW?
Eva: I'M SHORT.
MY SHOE IS TOO LITTLE.
I DIDN'T COMPLAIN.
J.: LIKE I ALWAYS SAY,
RUMORS DON'T START FROM NOTHIN'.
THEY DON'T JUST FALL OUT
THE SKY. IT'S CREATED.
SO I WILL BE ANNOUNCING
THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
TOMORROW MORNING, OKAY?
THANK YOU! HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.
Toccara: I DON'T KNOW HOW
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT SHE BLIND
WHEN SHE SAID SHE WAS OVER THERE
DOING THIS...
AND DOING THIS...
IT LOOKED LIKE YOU WEREN'T
WORRIED ABOUT NOT SEEING TO ME.
Yaya: BUT THEN IN THE ROOM,
SHE'S LIKE, "IS THIS A POLE?"
Amanda: THE GIRLS THINK
I'M EXAGGERATING MY BLINDNESS.
THE MAIN INSTIGATOR IS EVA.
I HAD A DREAM ABOUT HER WHERE
SHE WAS JUST, LIKE, BEING EVA.
AND I BEAT HER... ASS
INTO THE GROUND.
I WAS, LIKE, SLAMMING HER HEAD
AGAINST THE FLOOR.
Jennipher: WELL, SHE ACTS
SO TOUGH, BUT SHE'S NOT.
Amanda: NO, SHE'S NOT,
THAT'S WHY SHE'S SO LOUD
ALL THE TIME. SHE'S INSECURE.
Jennipher: I WANT SOMEONE
TO DOG HER ABOUT HER HEIGHT.
Amanda: (laughs)
Amanda: DO YOU KNOW WHERE
THE LAUNDRY CAME FROM,
OR WHERE IT WENT?
Cassie: YEAH, EVA BROUGHT IT.
Amanda: YEAH,
AND SHE "DOESN'T KNOW."
Nicole: AMANDA WAS THINKING
THAT HER BELONGINGS
WERE DISAPPEARING
AND THAT THERE WAS
A CERTAIN SOMEONE WHO HAD THEM.
Amanda: I FEEL THAT A LOT
OF PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE
DON'T TRUST EVA.
I'M MISSING $100.
MY SHIRT'S GONE.
MY LAUNDRY IS GONE.
SHE'S THE ONE
THAT DISTRIBUTED IT.
Jennipher: I'M MISSING STUFF.
AND I CAN'T FIGURE OUT
WHAT I'M MISSING EXACTLY,
BUT SOMEBODY HAS IT.
Amanda: ♪ I'M MISSING $100 ♪
♪ AND MY LAUNDRY'S GONE ♪
♪ 'CAUSE OF A CERTAIN BITCH
MMM! ♪
♪ CERTAIN BITCH ♪
♪ CERTAIN BITCH ♪♪
I DON'T KNOW IF I STARTED
THE INSTIGATION OF EVA,
BUT IT SUCKS THAT
THE LOUDEST PERSON
IS ALSO THE ONE
THAT YOU CAN'T TRUST.
Eva: WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
Amanda: I'M LOOKING
FOR MY BAG.
OKAY, BAIT ONE.
BAIT TWO.
SHE MIGHT NOT WANT IT,
'CAUSE THEY'RE UGLY.
I'M NOT LEAVING MY CRYSTALS OUT.
Nicole: I WASN'T NECESSARILY
IN SETTING THE TRAP,
I JUST KINDA WAS LIKE,
"HEY, THAT'S A GOOD IDEA."
Amanda: I'M GONNA LOSE
A LITTLE CASH, TOO.
WHAT'S A $10 BILL
TO CATCH A BITCH?
HMM?
BAM!
Nicole: I WROTE
"NICOLE'S SWEET ASS"
ON THE BILL SO THAT IF SOMEONE
DID TAKE IT,
WE WOULD KNOW WHO.
Amanda: ♪ DETECTIVE ♪
♪ DETECTIVE ♪♪
(knock on door)
Amanda: HELLO!
Cassie: J. CAME TO OUR HOUSE
TO ANNOUNCE WHO HAD WON
THE CHALLENGE
FROM THE HEATHERETTE SHOW
THE NIGHT BEFORE.
J.: UM, ANYWAY,
DID YOU RECOVER FROM LAST NIGHT?
Women: YEAH! YES!
J.: THE WINNER HAS TO CHOOSE
RIGHT AWAY TWO PEOPLE
TO GO WITH HER
ON A YACHT.
A PURE, ALL-DAY PAMPERING,
DARLINGS.
Eva: AAH!
J.: AND YOUR HOST WILL BE
PICKING YOU UP IN ONE HOUR.
SO WE'RE GONNA START
WITH MISS JENNIPHER.
BE A LITTLE LIGHTER
WHEN YOU WALK.
YOUR FEET CAN'T GUIDE YOU.
Jennipher: J.
CRITICIZED MY WALK.
IT'S KINDA FRUSTRATING BECAUSE
I TRY MY FIRST TIME
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
"OH, THAT SUCKS."
J.: AMANDA, YOU'RE JUST
TRYING TO BE A LITTLE TOO SEXY.
MISS EVA,
I WISH YOU WOULD'VE WORKED
THE CAPE JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE.
JUST A BIT MORE.
MISS ANN,
YOU WALK LIKE A DUDE.
YOU'RE JUST SO DAMN PRETTY.
MISS TOCCARA,
YOU HELD YOUR OWN, BABY.
YOU WERE MISS CROWD-PLEASER.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
I WAS AFRAID YOUR PUPPIES
WOULD GET OUT OF THE CAGE.
Eva: (laughs)
J.: OOH, I'M SO GLAD.
MISS KRISTI,
YOU LOOKED DOWN A LOT.
Kristi: MM-HMM.
I THINK I WAS LOOKING AT PEOPLE.
J.: IT'S SO IMPORTANT
FOR YOU NOT TO DO THAT.
Kristi: I'M FEELING LIKE
I DON'T HAVE ANY CONTROL
OVER THE THINGS THAT I'M DOING.
J.: AND, MISS NORELLE,
WELL, I LOVE IT
THAT IT WAS YOUR FAVORITE SHOW.
AND IT'S YOUR FAVORITE
DESIGNERS.
WE LIVE FOR THAT MOMENT.
AND YOU FALL DOWN IN IT.
YOU JUST TUMBLED.
IT WAS MAJOR.
SO THE WINNER
OF THIS COMPETITION
BECAUSE YOU NAILED IT,
AND WHEN I SAY, "NAILED IT,"
IS MISS EVA.
Eva: OH, YES!
J.: YOU NAILED IT. YOU DID.
Eva: IN YOUR
TALL BITCHES' FACE! YES!
J.: YOU DID ALL YOUR POSES.
YOU WORKED IT OUT.
Eva: WHEN I WON
THAT COMPETITION, I WAS STOKED.
I WAS BEYOND HAPPY.
J.: YOU COULDA WORKED
THAT CAPE A LITTLE BIT MORE,
BUT, YOU KNOW, YOU HIT IT.
YOU HIT IT.
Eva: THANK YOU.
J.: SO NOW YOU PICK--
Eva: ANNA-BANANA.
Ann: ALL RIGHT!
Eva: YOU KNOW WHAT? I'M GONNA
GO FOR A LONG SHOT HERE.
I'M PICKING KELLE.
Kelle: OH, MY GOD, EVA!
OH, MY GOD.
Eva: LET'S GET DRESSED,
BI-YOTCH.
Kelle: OH, MY GOD!
J.: AN HOUR,
YOU HAVE AN HOUR.
Kelle: I LOVE...
Eva: GET DRESSED!
GET DRESSED! GET DRESSED!
Amanda: IF ANYBODY
IN THE HOUSE BUT HER HAD WON,
WE WOULD'VE BEEN FINE.
Kelle: BIKINI!
YOUR FREAKIEST ONE.
Eva: BRING A BATHING SUIT
A BE WEARING A SKIRT.
Kelle: YEAH.
Eva: I WAS THINKING ABOUT
WEARING MY JUMPER THING.
Kelle: YOUR BLUE ONE?
THAT SAYS, "YACHT."
I CAN'T BELIEVE SHE CHOSE ME.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
Amanda: YEAH, DUDE,
BE CAREFUL.
Nicole: YEAH, NO KIDDING.
Kelle: THEY'RE GONNA
TRY TO CORRUPT ME.
Amanda: TRY TO--
JUST BE CAREFUL.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
Kelle: WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
Amanda: JUST DON'T GIVE
ANY INFORMATION OUT.
Amanda: HEY, MY CRYSTALS
ARE MISSING.
HAS ANYBODY SEEN MY CRYSTALS?
Eva: WHAT CRYSTALS?
Cassie: DO YOU WANT
SOME HELP?
Amanda: YEAH.
Eva: I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
Amanda: OH, OKAY.
Eva: EXCUSE YOU,
YOU JUST BUMPED INTO ME.
YOU KNOW THAT, RIGHT?
Amanda: IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
Eva: DON'T BE MAD, PLEASE.
IT'S NOT BECOMING.
Amanda: OH, NO, IT'S NOT
BECAUSE OF THE--OH, NO.
Eva: I'M NOT SAYING
BECAUSE OF THAT AT ALL.
I'M JUST SAYING, JUST,
WHATEVER YOU'RE MAD ABOUT,
DON'T BE MAD.
Amanda: I'VE GOT A, YOU KNOW,
RIGHT TO BE UPSET.
Eva: WELL, YOU DON'T HAVE
A RIGHT TO BUMP INTO ME
AND NOT SAY "EXCUSE ME."
Amanda: IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
Eva: DO YOU WANT ME TO
TO START--THEN SAY, "EXCUSE ME,"
THAT'S THE REASON FOR THE WORDS.
Amanda: BUT IF I DON'T FEEL
LIKE BEING EXCUSED...
Eva: ALL RIGHT, IT'S ON.
Amanda: THE REASON I'M MAD
IS SHE'S GANKING MY CRYSTALS.
Nicole: WE'LL FIND THEM.
Amanda: I'M NOT WALKING OUT
OF THIS HOUSE UNTIL I'VE GONE
THROUGH EVERYBODY'S POCKETS.
Jennipher: I'M GLAD WE HAVE
TIME TO CLEAN UP FINALLY.
Toccara: WE SHOULD HAVE
OUR OWN PARTY.
WE GOT THE CAKE.
I GOT THE STUFF.
Jennipher: I'M KINDA GLAD
SHE WON.
WE SHOULD A CAKE BAKE IN
CELEBRATION OF GETTING THE BITCH
OUT OF THE HOUSE FOR AN HOUR.
Yaya: OH, MY GOODNESS.
Toccara: OH, MY GOD.
Yaya: JENNIPHER WENT THERE.
Toccara: JENNIPHER BUSTS OUT,
"I'M GLAD THE BITCH GON' BE
GONE FOR A DAY."
AND SO EVA HEARS HER,
AND EVA THINKS THAT EVERYONE'S
MAD AT HER BECAUSE SHE WON
THE CONTEST.
Eva: THIS WHOLE THING
IS A FREAKIN' COMPETITION.
SO FIND YOUR NICHE
AND DO YOUR THING
AND DON'T HATE ON
THE NEXT PERSON WHEN THEY WIN.
Jennipher: I JUST DIDN'T LIKE
IT WHEN YOU GET UP AND YOU TRIED
TO DO IT IN EVERYBODY'S FACE.
YOU'RE LIKE,
"YOU SKINNY BITCHES."
Eva: I DIDN'T SAY "SKINNY,"
I SAID, "TALL."
Jennipher: SO YOU DON'T THINK
ANYBODY'S GONNA HATE
AGAINST THAT?
BECAUSE I WOULDN'T DO THAT.
Eva: BUT IT'S YOU, THOUGH.
MY PERSONALITY IS STILL EVA.
I'M NOT GONNA CHANGE
MY PERSONALITY JUST BECAUSE
I WON SOMETHING.
Jennipher: WELL, THEN WHY DO
YOU CHANGE YOUR PERSONALITY
WHEN YOU GO IN FRONT
OF THE JUDGES?
Eva: WHY WOULD I CHANGE
MY PERSONALITY?
Jennipher: YOU GET UP THERE,
AND YOU'RE ALL THIS.
WHY DON'T YOU BE THE BITCH DIVA
WHEN YOU'RE IN THERE?
Eva: BECAUSE I'M CUTE.
I'M SORRY, JENNIPHER, I AM.
Kristi: HEY, GUYS,
CAN YOU JUST KEEP IT A LITTLE
MORE QUIET BY THE PHONE? SORRY.
IT'S JUST MY BOYFRIEND CAN HEAR
EVERYTHING YOU'RE SAYING.
Jennipher: YOU TRY TO BE
LIKE, "OH, THIS IS WHO I AM."
THEN YOU GO IN FRONT OF OTHER
PEOPLE AND YOU'RE A BITCH.
WHY DON'T WE GO AROUND
AND ASK EVERY PERSON
HOW MUCH OF A BITCH YOU ARE?
Eva: WHY DON'T YOU GO AROUND
AND ASK EVERY PERSON?
Ann: YOU CHANGE
YOUR PERSONALITY.
Eva: ALL DAY.
YOU'RE TWO-FACED, EXTREMELY.
Jennipher: OH, I WAS NICE TO
YOU, AND I LIKED BOTH OF YOU.
AND THEN I GO IN THE ROOM,
AND I TALK ABOUT YOU RIGHT NOW.
Eva: YOU'RE A CHAMELEON.
YOU GO BACK AND FORTH.
Jennipher: OH, YOU'RE NOT?
Eva: HOW AM I A CHAMELEON?
Jennipher: YOU GO AND TELL
ME, "OH, AMANDA'S GETTING
SPECIAL TREATMENT FOR HER EYES."
AND THEN YESTERDAY YOU'RE ALL,
"I DIDN'T SAY THAT."
Amanda: "I HOPE
SHE'S NOT GONNA GET
SPECIAL TREATMENT."
Eva: THAT'S GREAT!
Amanda: THAT'S WHAT I HEARD
YOU SAY.
Ann: I'M NOT EVEN TRYING TO
BE RUDE, BUT TO US, TO SEE YOU,
LIKE GO UP TO J.--
Jennipher: TO US, TO US.
IT'S ALWAYS "US."
WHY DON'T YOU LET HER TALK?
Ann: NO, IT'S ME. THIS IS ME.
I'M ANN, AND I'M GONNA TELL HER
WHAT THE... I THINK.
SO YOU CAN SHUT YOUR MOUTH.
THIS IS WHAT I SAID,
"YOU KNOW WHAT? I DON'T FEEL--"
Jennipher: GET OUT
OF THE WAY.
Ann: DON'T EVER
TOUCH ME AGAIN, OR ELSE
YOU WILL GET KNOCKED OUT.
Jennipher: OH,
I'D LIKE TO SEE IT.
Ann: GOOD.
Amanda: "I HOPE SHE'S NOT
GONNA GET SPECIAL TREATMENT."
Eva: THAT'S GREAT.
Amanda: THAT'S WHAT
I HEARD YOU SAY.
Ann: I DON'T FEEL--
Jennipher: LET ME
OUT OF THE WAY.
Ann: DON'T EVER
TOUCH ME AGAIN, OR ELSE
YOU WILL GET KNOCKED OUT.
Jennipher: OH,
I'D LIKE TO SEE IT.
Ann: GOOD.
Amanda: YOU KNOW, I'M NOT MAD
AT YOU FOR WINNING.
THE PROBLEM I HAVE--
Eva: I DIDN'T EVEN THINK
YOU WERE MAD AT ME FOR WINNING.
Amanda: WHAT DO YOU THINK
I'M MAD AT YOU ABOUT?
Eva: I DON'T KNOW. BUT I KNOW
WHEN YOU BUMPED ME RIGHT HERE,
LITTLE MISS SWEET AMANDA
DIDN'T SAY "EXCUSE ME."
Amanda: I DON'T HAVE TO SAY
"EXCUSE ME."
Eva: BECAUSE OF
YOUR PERSONALITY, THE WAY AMANDA
WOULD USUALLY REACT, WOULD BE,
"EXCUSE ME, I'M SORRY."
YES, IT WOULD.
AND DON'T PLAY THE ROLE.
EVERYBODY'S PLAYING
A ROLE TODAY.
GET OVER IT!
Kelle: LET'S GO!
Toccara: LOOK AT KELLE.
LOOK AT KELLE.
Eva: THAT WAS SO "EXTRA."
EXTRA, EXTRA, READ ALL ABOUT IT!
Kelle: DOES ANYONE HAVE
AN EXTRA PAIR OF SUNGLASSES,
SPEAKING OF EXTRA?
Amanda: THAT--THAT BUMP?
STAND UP FOR A SECOND.
LET ME DEMONSTRATE.
Yaya: OKAY.
THAT'S NOT...
THAT'S NOT SIGNIFICANT.
Eva: OKAY,
WHAT BATHING SUIT DO I WEAR?
Kelle: YOU WEAR THIS ONE.
Eva: THIS AND THOSE?
Kelle: YES.
Amanda: I DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE CLOTHES, YOU KNOW?
Yaya: YEAH, I UNDERSTAND,
YOUR CRYSTALS.
Amanda: I KEEP THEM
ON MY DRESSER.
AND I WAS CARRYING
THEM AROUND YESTERDAY
BECAUSE I WAS VERY UPSET.
MY MONEY CAN BE GONE,
BUT YOU DON'T TAKE MY CRYSTALS--
THE THING THAT MEANS
THE MOST TO ME.
THE THING THAT
GIVES ME STRENGTH
AND TAKES AWAY MY NEGATIVITY.
Yaya: ARE THEY JUST CRYSTALS
LYING AROUND,
OR ARE THEY IN A BAG?
Amanda: THEY'RE LIKE A ROCK.
Toccara: EXCUSE ME, EVERYONE,
HAVE ANYONE SEEN
AMANDA'S CRYSTALS?
Ann: CRYSTALS?
Eva: I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT SHE'S TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN SHE SAYS, "HER CRYSTALS."
Ann: CAN YOU TELL JENNIPHER
NEVER TO TOUCH ME AGAIN?
'CAUSE, LIKE, I SWEAR TO GOD,
I WANNA GO AND SAY SOMETHING
RIGHT NOW.
Kelle: UM,
I NEED TO FIND SUNGLASSES.
Ann: I MIGHT BE SKINNY,
BUT I CAN PUNCH.
AND I WILL KNOCK YOU OUT,
LIKE, I SWEAR TO GOD.
Eva: HAVE YOU SEEN
ANN'S BICEPS?
ANN WILL BEAT YOUR ASS, JEN.
FIRST OF ALL,
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
YOU WERE A BITCH.
I DIDN'T.
BUT NOW I SEE IT...
ALL THE TIME.
Jennipher: YEAH,
I CAN BE A BITCH.
Eva: YEAH, I KNOW.
THE FACT THAT YOU TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE, THE THINGS YOU SAID
ABOUT PEOPLE, BUT WHAT
WHAT PISSES ME OFF EVEN MORE
IS THAT YOU DON'T HAVE THE...
TO GO AND SAY IT TO THEM.
AND YOU DON'T GO SAY IT TO THEM.
AND THAT'S WHY I DON'T LIKE YOU.
Kelle: DOES ANYONE
HAVE A PAIR OF SUNGLASSES?
Eva: IT'S A COMPETITION.
YOU NEED TO KEEP
YOUR FOCUS IN THIS.
NOBODY'S FOCUSED RIGHT NOW.
Kelle: I'M JUST LIKE,
"WHOO-HOO, OKAY, I'M SORRY,
BUT WE REALLY DON'T
HAVE TIME TO TALK.
WE HAVE A YACHT TO CATCH."
Toccara: HI!
Yoanna: HI, HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
Kelle: HI!
Yoanna: HEY!
Eva: I WAS EXTREMELY EXCITED
TO GO ON THE YACHT,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE ALL THE DRAMA
WAS GOING ON IN THE HOUSE.
IT WAS GONNA BE A DAY OF LUXURY,
AND YOANNA WAS TAKING US.
Kelle: OH, WOW.
WE GET TO THE YACHT,
WE GO UPSTAIRS.
AND THEY HAVE ALL OF THESE COOL
HAND SANDWICHES.
OOH!
Man: I CAN ALSO BRING YOU
SOMETHING TO DRINK,
IF YOU'D LIKE.
Eva: WATERS
ALL THE WAY AROUND.
Eva: IT WAS REALLY COOL
TO JUST BE OUTSIDE THE HOUSE
AND SIT AND RELAX.
Yoanna: AMBER VALETTA.
Eva: SHE HAS A CAMPAIGN
WITH LOUIS VUITTON.
Yoanna: SHE'S HAD
A LOT OF CAMPAIGNS.
Eva: WHO'S THAT?
Yoanna: INEZ.
Ann: IT WAS GOOD
TO MEET YOANNA
AND TALK TO HER LIKE I TALK
TO ANY OF MY FRIENDS.
Yoanna: WHAT KIND OF SHOES
ARE THOSE?
Ann: THESE?
Eva: ANN IS EXCITED
TO BE WITH YOANNA. SHE LOVED IT.
AND SHE'S EXTREMELY STARSTRUCK,
BUT SHE'S FROM
ERIE, PENNSYLVANIA.
Amanda: I JUST FEEL BETTER
RIGHT NOW.
Yaya: YOU FEEL BETTER?
Amanda: MM-HMM.
Yaya: GOOD.
Amanda: I FOUND MY CRYSTALS.
Yaya: YOU FOUND THEM?!
YOU'RE ALL SECRETIVE ABOUT IT.
Nicole: WHERE WERE THEY?
Amanda: I'M AN IDIOT.
I HID 'EM LAST NIGHT.
I HID THEM SO THEY WOULDN'T
GET STOLEN.
I FEEL, LIKE, REALLY SILLY
FOR, LIKE, ACCUSING SOMEBODY
OF THEFT WITHOUT HAVING
ANY PROOF.
Eva: HOLD ON, NO,
I DIDN'T FIGURE THIS OUT.
UNLESS YOU HAVE PROOF, DON'T SAY
I TOOK ANYTHING FROM YOU.
Amanda: OKAY,
THAT WAS WRONG OF ME TO, LIKE,
JUMP TO A CONCLUSION, BUT...
Eva: ALL I KNOW--
Amanda: I JUST FIND IT
KIND OF ODD THAT, YOU KNOW,
MINE THAT WAS THE ONLY STUFF
THAT ISN'T EVEN ANYWHERE.
YOU KNOW?
Eva: HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT THAT
YOU MIGHT'VE MISPLACED THEM?
HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT
IT MIGHT'VE BEEN ON YOU?
Amanda: HEY, IF YOU ACCEPT
AN APOLOGY, I'LL MAKE IT SAYING,
"SORRY I ASSUMED SOMETHING."
Ann: SO LET'S JUST DROP IT
AT THAT. YAY!
Amanda: YAY!
Eva: I'M NOT A THIEF.
I MAY BE LOUD,
BUT I'M NOT A THIEF.
Yaya: TYRA MAIL.
"CAN YOU STAND OUT IN A CROWD?
BE READY AT 8:30
IN THE MORNING."
Women: WHOO!
Woman: ♪ CONFUSION ♪♪
Toccara: WE GET THIS TYRA MAIL
AND IT SAYS,
"CAN YOU STAND OUT IN A CROWD?
BE READY AT 8:30."
Jay: TODAY YOU GUYS WILL BE
IN A GROUP SHOT
DOING A SHOOT FOR LEE JEANS,
AND YOU GUYS WILL BE WEARING
LEE JEANS AND NOTHING ELSE.
Women: WHOO!
Kristi: I KNEW THAT THERE
WOULD BE A TIME
WHEN WE'D HAVE TO GET NAKED.
MY FAMILY, I CAN TELL YOU NOW,
IS NOT GONNA LIKE IT VERY MUCH.
Jay: HERE'S THE REAL
COOL PART--
THIS LEE JEANS
DOUBLE-PAGE SPREAD IS GOING
TO APPEAR AS AN ADVERTISEMENT
IN "PEOPLE" MAGAZINE.
Women: WHOO! YAY!
Jay: YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY
IS SO TALENTED. I LOVE HIM.
HIS NAME IS HYUNGWAN ROO.
HYUNGWAN,
COULD YOU COME OVER HERE?
Hyungwan: EVERYBODY NEEDS
TO BE SORT OF "ON"
AT THE SAME TIME.
SO I JUST NEED
YOUR UNDIVIDED ATTENTION.
Jay: WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
SHOOT YOU GUYS IN TWO GROUPS
OF SIX AND FIVE
AND COMPOSITE THEM TOGETHER.
ALL RIGHT?
Women: ALL RIGHT.
Jay: ALL RIGHT,
SO LET'S GET STARTED.
Eva: WHEN WE'RE IN THE HOUSE,
THAT'S NOT THE COMPETITION.
WHEN WE GET ON THAT SET,
THAT IS THE COMPETITION.
Cassie: MAKE ME LOOK SEXY.
I NEED TO LOOK HIGH FASHION.
Mathu: THINK
OLIVIA NEWTON-JOHN IN "GREASE."
Kristi: I WOULD HATE TO,
LIKE, TRAVEL ALL OVER THE PLACE
EVERY OTHER WEEK
AND NOT SEE YOUR FAMILY.
Danilo: THERE'S JUST A POINT
THAT YOUR FRIENDS STOP CALLING.
Kristi: WHOO.
Jay: DON'T WORRY.
THE GIRLS CLEARLY HAD
NO PROBLEMS THROWING
THEIR TOPS OFF.
Nicole: WHATEVER.
TOPLESS DOESN'T BOTHER ME.
Amanda: YEAH,
IT WAS GONNA BE A HOT SHOT.
Norelle: I FELT TOTALLY
COMFORTABLE BEING TOPLESS,
BECAUSE I LOVE MY BOOBS.
Kristi: I WAS REALLY NERVOUS.
I WAS TRYING TO ACT
ALL COMFORTABLE AND CONFIDENT
WHEN I TOTALLY WAS NOT.
Jay: OH, ANN, WOW.
THERE'S A GOOD ONE.
Amanda: (laughs)
Hyungwan: KRISTI, STAY FACED
TOWARDS THE CAMERA
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
Kristi: ALL THE WAY THIS WAY?
Hyungwan: NO,
THAT'S TOO MUCH.
Jay: YOU'D EXPECT KRISTI TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO CHEAT HER JAW
SO IT WOULDN'T LOOK AS LARGE,
AND SHE JUST KEPT PUSHING
IT OUT.
HEY, KELLE...
DON'T DO THIS.
Kelle: OKAY.
Jay: HEY, NICOLE,
WATCH THAT PINKIE FINGER.
BRING IT IN.
ARE YOU GUYS LISTENING?
DON'T LOSE IT.
Ann: AND TO THINK WE ALL
THOUGHT THIS WAS EASY.
Hyungwan: GREAT!
Women: WHOO! YES!
Jay: YOU GET POINTS
FOR REHEARSING ON THE FLOOR.
Norelle: WE'RE PRACTICING.
Jay: OH, EVA,
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
SOMETHING ABOUT HER HEAD.
TOCCARA LOOKS SO PERFECT.
Michele: NOT EVEN
ONE BAD PICTURE.
Jay: MNH-MNH.
Hyungwan: NORELLE,
COVER YOUR BREAST
JUST A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
Jay: JENNIPHER,
CAN YOU TURN YOUR HEAD A LITTLE
TO FACE THE CAMERA?
Jennipher: WHEN WE
DO PHOTO SHOOTS,
IF IT FEELS UNCOMFORTABLE,
IT'S PROBABLY RIGHT.
Jay: UGH.
Hyungwan: YOUR UPPER BODY,
JUST ANGLE THE WHOLE THING.
YAYA, YOU'RE GREAT.
Jay: WHAT HAPPENED
TO NORELLE?
DON'T FORGET THAT PROFILE.
YOU GUYS ROCKED.
GOOD JOB TODAY.
I'M REALLY SURPRISED.
SO THROW YOUR TOPS ON.
Jay: NORELLE...
WAS TRYING TO SHOW ME
HOW GORGEOUS HER BOOBS WERE,
WHICH THEY ARE.
IF SHE'S GOT GORGEOUS BOOBS
THAT DOESN'T MEAN SHE'S GOING
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Kelle: WE'VE GOT TYRA MAIL!
Eva: TYRA MAIL!
Kelle: TOMORROW YOU MEET
THE JUDGES.
ONLY TEN OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
ON HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Kristi: YOANNA SAID
TO NOT PAY ATTENTION
TO THE OTHER GIRLS.
DON'T GET DISTRACTED.
I DON'T GOOF OFF AT ALL.
BUT IN THIS SITUATION I HAVE
FELT TOTALLY OUT OF CONTROL.
Eva: MY PRIORITIES
ARE TO WIN THIS COMPETITION,
AND I'M GONNA WIN IT.
WHAT IF I GOT ELIMINATED?
WOW, WOULDN'T THAT BE A SHOCKER?
Norelle: I MIGHT BE AT
A DISADVANTAGE BECAUSE I DID,
LIKE, FALL.
I THINK THAT MIGHT COUNT
AGAINST ME.
I'M HERE, LIKE,
TO WIN THE COMPETITION.
IT BOTHERS ME.
LIKE, I DON'T WANNA GO HOME.
Jennipher: WE HAVE
AN ELIMINATION TONIGHT.
AND, YEAH, I'M KINDA NERVOUS.
I FEEL THAT I'M GONNA
MAKE IT REALLY FAR IN THIS,
AND THAT'S HOW I THINK
IT'S GONNA PLAY OUT FOR ME.
Amanda: WE ALL KNOW THAT
WE COULD MODEL.
BUT ARE WE GOOD ENOUGH
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
Tyra: SO THIS WEEK
YOU LEARNED HOW TO WALK
THE CATWALK
FROM MISS DIVA EXTRAORDINAIRE
J. ALEXANDER.
AND YOU DID YOUR VERY FIRST
FASHION SHOW.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME FOR
THE JUDGING PANEL TO MAKE
THEIR FOURTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
IN DETERMINING WHO WILL BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NOW LET ME TALK ABOUT
THE PRIZES.
YOU'LL RECEIVE
A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH THE TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING AGENCY FORD MODELS,
A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD-RENOWNED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
NOW I'M GONNA INTRODUCE
OUR PANEL OF CRAZY-ASS
BUT SO EXCITING JUDGES.
FIRST WE HAVE
MISS JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS ONE OF THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPER-DUPER MODELS.
NIGEL BARKER, WHO IS A NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
Nigel: THANK YOU.
Tyra: NOLE MARIN,
WHO IS A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
AND IF YOU LOOK OVER HERE,
WE HAVE TWO GORGEOUS,
FABULOUS GUEST JUDGES,
HEATHERETTE.
Janice: (screams)
Richie: THANKS FOR HAVING US.
YOW!
Tyra: MISS J. WILL NOW
ADMINISTER YOUR TEST.
J.: OKAY, GIRLS,
YOU HAVE TO WALK
IN A PAIR OF SHOES
THAT ARE TWO SIZES TOO SMALL.
AND WITH THIS YOU'LL BE
IN AN UGLY PINK DRESS.
Richie: AND WE DIDN'T
MAKE IT.
Women: (laugh)
J.: OKAY, SO, GIRLS,
GO IN THE BACK AND CHANGE.
THANK YOU.
Janice: WORK IT!
Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR LEE JEANS.
HERE'S THE ACTUAL AD THAT WILL
RUN IN "PEOPLE" MAGAZINE.
Janice: OH, VERY '60s.
VERY ACID-TRIPPY.
I REMEMBER.
Tyra: UP FIRST, CASSIE.
Cassie: I DIDN'T THINK
MY FOOT WAS GONNA GO
IN THIS SHOE.
Nolé: YOU CAN'T LET US
SEE THAT PAIN.
YOU'RE GONNA BE DOING
SHOW AFTER SHOW
AND ALL SMALL SHOES.
YOU'RE GONNA BE BROKEN DOWN.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: CASSIE, I THINK
I THINK THIS IS ONE
OF YOUR BEST PICTURES TO DATE.
Nigel: VERY BROOKE SHIELDS.
Tyra: NICOLE.
Richie: I COULD SEE YOUR FACE
LIKE, ON A BOX OF HAIR COLOR.
I REALLY DIDN'T SEE YOU
AS A RUNWAY MODEL TO BE HONEST.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: VERY ANDROGYNOUS,
I ADORE IT.
Tyra: KELLE.
I'M SORRY.
Tyra: WHEN YOU STARTED
FEELING THE PAIN OF THOSE SHOES,
YOU GAVE UP.
THE BEST ATHLETES,
THE BEST DANCERS
AND THE BEST MODELS
PUSH THROUGH THE PAIN.
Nigel: WELL, YOU LOOK
A LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE HERE.
Janice: KINDA LOOKING LIKE
BREAST EXAM TO ME.
Kelle: OH, GOD, PLEASE, NO.
Tyra: YOUR BODY LOOKS GOOD,
BUT JUST THE FACE--
Kelle: I LOOK LIKE
A PLATYPUS.
Janice: OH, SNAP OUT OF IT.
THIS IS VALUABLE ADVICE
WE'RE GIVING YOU.
Kelle: NO, IT IS, I KNOW.
Janice: OKAY,
SIT THERE AND TAKE IT, HONEY.
Tyra: ANN.
Janice: YOU CAME OUT
LIKE AN EAST GERMAN SWIMMER.
Tyra: YOU HAVE TO LEARN HOW
TO TAKE THE STRENGTH
FROM BEING AN ATHLETE,
BUT THEN GET THE SEX APPEAL
AND THE STOMP
AND THE FIERCENESS
OF BEING A MODEL.
WOW, ANN!
Nigel: YOU LOOK GORGEOUS.
Tyra: I'M LIKE, "OH, MY GOD."
Nigel: I'M LIKE, "THANK GOD."
Tyra: AMANDA.
Nigel: NEVER LOOK DOWN.
DO YOU WEAR GLASSES?
DO YOU WEAR CONTACTS?
Amanda: I HAVE
AN EYE DISEASE.
I'M LEGALLY BLIND.
I'M ASSUMING IN AROUND
FIVE YEARS,
I'M GONNA BE COMPLETELY BLIND.
Janice: OH, I'VE WALKED OFF
OF PLENTY OF RUNWAYS, TRUST ME.
Nigel: NONETHELESS,
THIS IS SOMETHING
YOU WILL HAVE TO DO.
HOWEVER, YOU CAN OVERCOME IT.
Janice: LADY GODIVA.
Nigel: NICE.
IT STILL LOOKS PRETTY GOOD.
Tyra: IT'S EDGY.
Nolé: NO MATTER WHAT ANGLE
YOU SHOOT,
YOU COME ACROSS BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: KRISTI.
Janice: I THINK
YOU LOOK BORED.
Nigel: I ALMOST BACKED UP
IN MY CHAIR,
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WAS LIKE
A TRAIN WRECK COMING TOWARDS ME.
Tyra: THE LAST
VICTORIA'S SECRET FASHION SHOW,
I HAD A SIZE 7 1/2 SHOE.
I WEAR A SIZE 10.
FOR SOME REASON,
WHEN I'M ON THE RUNWAY,
THE PAIN GOES AWAY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THE GAME FACE.
Kristi: IT'S, LIKE,
NOT COMING AS FAST
AS I WOULD LIKE.
Tyra: THERE WAS A GROUP SHOT
FOR LEE JEANS,
AND HERE IS YOUR CLOSE-UP.
Nigel: I DON'T KNOW.
IT LOOKS UNCOMFORTABLE.
Tyra: LOOKS A LITTLE CHINISH.
RELAX THAT.
LIKE, YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE PICTURE RIGHT NOW,
AND YOU LOOK GORGEOUS.
NORELLE.
Janice: ONE LEG, HOP.
Nolé: YOU LOOK LIKE
THE BROKEN TIN MAN.
YOU NEEDED A MAJOR OIL JOB.
I MEAN, AND QUICK.
Norelle: I'VE NEVER
WALKED IN HEELS EVER.
Janice: I WAS IN HEELS
WHEN I WAS, LIKE, 7.
Traver: YOU NEED TO START
EAT, SLEEPING AND DRINKING--
Richie: YEAH, IN HEELS.
Nigel: THAT'S MAYBE THE BEST
PICTURE I'VE SEEN OF YOU.
Tyra: THE OTHER GIRLS
NEED TO BE SCURRED.
TOCCARA.
Tyra: HOW ARE
YOUR FEET FEELING?
Toccara: UGH.
Janice: (laughs)
Toccara: OH, MY GOD,
THEY HURT SO BAD.
Nigel: YOU ARE COMFORTABLE
WITH YOUR BODY.
YOU ARE SEXY WITH YOUR BODY.
Nolé: YOU BRING FORTH
A STRONG, CONFIDENT,
BEAUTIFUL WOMAN.
Richie: WHOA.
Tyra: WOW.
Janice: ONE BOOTYLICIOUS
SHOT.
Tyra: I WOULD'VE LIKED YOU
TO POP THAT BOOTY A LITTLE BIT
MORE BEYONCE-ED OUT.
EVA.
Janice: OOPS.
Richie: ON THE RUNWAY
I FEEL LIKE YOU'RE VERY DAINTY.
I DON'T THINK THAT FITS
YOUR PERSONALITY.
Nolé: I WANNA SEE THAT TOUGH,
SEXY, GORGEOUS
LITTLE TOMBOY ON THE RUNWAY.
Janice: GORGEOUS!
Richie: WOW.
Tyra: THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
Nolé: IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE SCARED.
Tyra: I FEEL LIKE YOU
JUST LOOK A LITTLE STIFF.
YAYA.
Tyra: IT REMINDED ME
OF "COMING TO AMERICA."
YOU HAD YOUR HEAD UP.
I WAS LIKE, "WHAT IS SHE DOING?"
THAT IS NOT MODELING.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Nolé: THAT IS FABULOUS.
Richie: I LOVE IT.
Janice: CAN'T TOP THAT.
Tyra: THAT'S AMAZING.
Nolé: ONE OF THE BEST SHOTS
TONIGHT.
Nigel: YEAH.
Tyra: JENNIPHER.
(record needle scratches)
Janice: OH, MY GOD.
OH, MY GOD.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
WHAT WAS UP WITH
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
ON YOUR BOOTY?
Jennipher: FOR MY BUTT.
I WAS GONNA SHOW A LITTLE BIT,
I JUST MIGHT AS WELL
GET IT NOTICED.
Janice: THAT'S, LIKE,
LICENSE TO GET FIRED,
PLAYING THAT KIND OF A JOKE
ON A RUNWAY.
Tyra: HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
Janice: PICTURE, I'M SORRY.
I DON'T LIKE IT.
Nolé: I HAVE NOTHING POSITIVE
TO SAY.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE
TO DETERMINE WHICH ONE OF YOU
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED.
Tyra: YAYA.
Nolé: I DID NOT CARE FOR
THE WAY SHE WORKED
THE RUNWAY AT ALL,
AND I FELT THAT HER DANCE
TRAINING WORKED AGAINST HER.
Tyra: ANN.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT
SHE ACTUALLY TOOK THIS PICTURE.
DANG, THERE IS SOME
POTENTIAL HERE.
TOCCARA.
Traver: IN OUR FASHION SHOW
SHE GOT THE BIGGEST CHEER.
I COULD HEAR THE CROWD SCREAMING
FROM BACKSTAGE.
Nolé: SHE PHOTOGRAPHS
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING
WEEK AFTER WEEK.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Janice: THE HEEL THING?
COME ON, YOU GUYS ARE GAY MEN.
SPEAK UP.
Richie: IN JUNIOR HIGH YOU WEAR
HEELS TO A PROM, DON'T YOU?
I WORE HEELS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
Tyra: KELLE.
Nigel: THE PICTURE
HAS FALLEN APART.
Janice: BUT I'M NOT FEELING
KELLE'S FACE.
Nolé: I'M LOSING HER.
Tyra: KRISTI.
Nigel: THIS IS A VERY SCARY
PICTURE OF KRISTI.
Janice: I GET A SENSE
OF CAROL BURNETT WITH THE JAW.
Tyra: NICOLE.
Janice: I HAVE A PENCHANT
FOR NICOLE'S FLAMING RED HAIR.
Tyra: EVA.
Nigel: SHE'S UNUSUAL.
SHE'S SHORT. SHE'S BOYISH.
Nolé: EVA IS
MISS GOLDEN DELICIOUS.
Tyra: CASSIE.
Nigel: SHE'S VERY PRETTY.
Janice: SHE'S JUST TIRED.
MAYBE LIKE SHE HASN'T SLEPT
FOR THE LAST MONTH.
GOD KNOWS I DIDN'T SLEEP
FOR TEN YEARS.
Tyra: AMANDA.
Nigel: YOU CAN'T BE BLIND
AND BE WALKING ON CATWALKS.
Janice: AMANDA'S HANDICAP
IS NOT AN ISSUE FOR ME.
SHE PHOTOGRAPHS AMAZINGLY.
Nigel: I'M SORRY. TELL ME AN
AGENT THAT'S GOING TO TAKE ON
A LEGALLY BLIND MODEL?
Tyra: JENNIPHER.
Nolé: MAJOR DISAPPOINTMENT
FOR ME.
AND I DIDN'T THINK
SHE UNDERSTANDS THIS BUSINESS.
Richie: I WANNA LOVE HER,
BUT I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE I DO.
Janice: BYE-BYE.
Tyra: THERE ARE 11 BEAUTIFUL
GIRLS STANDING BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE TEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
THESE TEN PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE YOUNG LADIES THAT WILL STILL
BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME THAT I'M GOING
TO CALL...
CASSIE.
CONGRATULATIONS. YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Cassie: THANK YOU.
Tyra: ANN.
THIS IS THE BIG SHOCK GIRL.
THIS PICTURE PROVED
EVERYONE WRONG.
NICOLE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Nicole: THANK YOU.
Tyra: TOCCARA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Toccara: THANK YOU.
Tyra: EVA.
AMANDA.
NORELLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Norelle: THANK YOU.
Tyra: YAYA.
I HAVE TWO PICTURES LEFT.
Tyra: KELLE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Kelle: THANK YOU.
Tyra: WILL JENNIPHER
AND KRISTI PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS ONE PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE GIRL'S NAME THAT
I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO THE APARTMENT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND LEAVE.
JENNIPHER,
SOMETIMES YOU CAN WANT SOMETHING
SO BAD, BUT IF YOU CAN'T CONVEY
IT TO SOMEONE ELSE,
THEN IT DOESN'T COUNT,
BECAUSE THEN THEY CAN'T FEEL IT.
AND I KNOW YOU WERE TRYING
TO BE CUTE WITH THE "A-N-T-M"
ON THE BOOTY.
WELL, IT KINDA FLOPPED.
KRISTI,
THERE'S AN INSECURITY
THAT YOU HAVE,
THAT THE JUDGES AREN'T SURE
IS REPAIRABLE.
A LOT OF THE JUDGES
ARE CONCERNED WITH YOUR MOUTH.
I'M NOT SO CONCERNED
WITH YOUR MOUTH.
EVERY MODEL HAS SOMETHING
THAT IS BEAUTIFUL AND QUIRKY
THAT SHE HAS TO LEARN TO MASTER.
Tyra: JENNIPHER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANKS, KRISTI.
Kristi: I'M DISAPPOINTED JUST
BECAUSE I KNOW I CAN DO BETTER.
I DON'T LIKE FAILING, AND THAT'S
WHAT I FEEL LIKE I DID.
I NEED TO GET AWAY
FROM MODELING FOR AWHILE
AND FIGURE OUT WHAT IT IS
THAT I LIKE ABOUT IT
AND HOW MUCH
I WANNA PURSUE IT.
IT DOESN'T DISCOURAGE ME
ENTIRELY, IT JUST MAKES ME WANNA
RETHINK THINGS.
IT'S A REALLY INTIMATE THING
TO LEARN,
AND I FEEL LIKE I CAN
BETTER DO IT AT HOME.
Tyra: STAY TUNES FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
Tyra: COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"--
IN A HEART-TO-HEART TALK,
TOCCARA OPENS UP
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
Toccara: WHY ARE YOU
MAKING ME CRY, TYRA?
Tyra: THE COMPETITION
STARTS TO WEIGH ON KELLE.
AND THE UNPREDICTABLE
JANICE DICKINSON
DOES HER THING.
Janice: IMPORTANT NOT TO LOOK
LIKE A PORN STAR. HELLO.